françaises français
[Musique]
vous qui m'écoutent et mon françaises et
français qui met côté nous ne faisons
absolument aucune confiance aux
bulletins de vote un enfant
dévorer
[Musique]
justice sociale du stockage utile
d'otages bois devant vous un verre d'eau
je voulais regarder la france au fond
des yeux
travailleuses travailleurs
vive la république
les bleus
ont tous les cas c'est la france que
j'aime et ce que demain
la france ressemblera à cette table là
nous allons être progressivement
submergé travailler plus pour gagner
davantage
[Applaudissements]
à chaque élection présidentielle c'est
un exercice obligé pour tous les
candidats à la magistrature suprême ne
les clips de campagne ses clips diffusés
en prime time à la télévision nous en
apprennent beaucoup sur les candidats
leurs programmes et l'évolution des
techniques de communication politique
dynamique qu'on passait ou surprenants
ils nous permettent aussi de revisiter
de manière originale les cinq décennies
passées voici l'histoire de 10 campagne
présidentielle avec son candidat emile
clean qui sont souvent annonciateur
d'une victoire ou d'une défaite
dimanche prochain
en élisant le chef de l'état
vous aurez à désigner le français que
vous estimez en conscience le plus digne
et le plus capable de représenter la
france est de garantir son destin
notre histoire commence lors de
l'élection présidentielle de 1965 c'est
une époque où la télévision est
entièrement dévoué au pouvoir du général
de gaulle président depuis sept ans dans
des clips de campagne financée par
l'état l'opposition est pour la première
fois autorisé à s'exprimer à la
télévision publique qu'on appelle alors
le rtf
[Musique]
en 65 la télévision depuis 58 mais elle
l'était déjà avant et est totalement
sous contrôle du pouvoir politique
général de gaulle considère que la peau
des télévisions fait partie de ses
prérogatives mais tout de même on est
dans un monde quand même qui a quand
même évolué en particulier dans les
exemples étrangers états unis
l'angleterre montre que la télévision ça
peut être autre chose et à ce moment là
il décide le grès son gouvernement
décide qu'on va donner la parole aux
oppositions ce qui nous vaut
le candidat de la gauche françois
mitterrand s'empare de l'occasion oui
ce dialogue qui commence aujourd'hui
entre nous je l'espérais depuis
longtemps
je suis candidat contre le général de
gaulle me contre lui seul car lui seul
compte à droite
mais ce n'est pas une affaire facile
ce n'est pas une affaire facile en effet
et en particulier pour les clips de
campagne télévisée où les candidats
doivent s'exprimer pendant 15 minutes
d'affilée de gaulle au pouvoir depuis
sept ans a appris à maîtriser
parfaitement cet exercice puisqu'il va
dépendre
de vous toutes et le vous tous
que je poursuive ou non ma mission
il ne trouve pas anormal de parler face
à une caméra est quelque chose de
totalement aberrant quand on est un
humain et je crois que son côté en
majesté
lui rend les choses plus faciles cic qui
s'adresse aux français je parle pas de
l'appel du 18 juin mais c'était la même
chose on parlait un micro et en
s'adressant aux gens donc je pense que
cet exercice solennelle de parler à tous
les français sans les voir ils le
maîtrisent effectivement bien parce que
il s'adresse en hauteur on dirait
aujourd'hui en tout verticalité aux
français et c'est quelque chose qu'il va
bien même physiquement c'est qu'il se
tient droit il parle et l'allocution est
parfaite françaises français
continueront la force
il joue la république
c'est à l'écriture que se joue des mots
qui fusent et les formules qui vont
faire cacher comme en écrivant qu'elle
se trouve donc en écrivain son discours
et en la prenant par coeur et en le
répétant devant la glace pendant des
heures jusqu'à arriver au mot près ce
qu'ils voulaient dire c'est quand même
extraordinaire comme performant en faire
un immense talent un immense talent mais
une immense fois une immense conviction
il savait dompter l'appareil est bien
françois mitterrand je vais d'abord vous
poser une question d'ordre général une
journaliste amie aide de son côté le
candidat de la gauche qui a beaucoup
plus de mal à dompter la caméra il n'a
pas l'expérience de de gaulle comme le
montre cet extrait non diffusés 14
semaines de congés sans salaire et qu'on
sait d'autre part que
c'est une erreur
on recommence tant pis je pense que pour
mitterrand qui est habitué à des salles
de meeting parce que sa politique c'est
pas la même chose c'est pas le même
rapport à la politique de gaulle
mitterrand a besoin d'avoir un humain
qui parle être capable de faire à
une prise en une seule prise 15 minutes
pour parler aux gens surtout quand on a
effectivement qu'un objectif de caméra
en face c'est pas quelque chose de
naturel voici notre première rencontre
vous allez donner vos voix
il est naturel que vous connaissiez
celui qui voulait demande surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un homme neuf
il y en a beaucoup plus à l'aise avec
l'image c'est le candidat centriste jean
lecanuet qui va marquer les esprits avec
son sourire sourire c'est pas trés c'est
pas trés vème république à l'époque mais
à côté de ce visage on trouve
l'annoncent des émissions de télévision
qui aura avoir lieu qu il faudra
regarder donc et techniques électorales
sont là et ça va être véritablement une
révolution la fiche électorale
est sacré en france la première qui
compte c'est de le canut et un
dent-blanche haleine fraîche moi j'ai
appelé un qui avait d'ailleurs remporté
le premier des techniques américaines
ici tu aimais même fait blanchir les
dents les premiers français et c'est les
blanchir les dents aux états unis
par rapport à vos récents sont souvent
elle est restée dans l'histoire de
france je suis jean le camus et j'ai 45
ans c'est l'âge des responsables des
grandes nations modernes lequel lui même
dans ses spots dit il ya de jeunes chefs
d'état un peu partout dans le monde et
je veux m'inscrire dans ce mouvement là
ça soit aussi par contraste avec le
général de gaulle qui est glissante je
pouvoir depuis sept ans qu'il beaucoup
plus âgées ça passe notamment par
l'image il dit écoutez vous avez besoin
de me connaître alors je vais me
présenter je suis jean le camus et j'ai
été là j'ai un voile et asseoir la de
gaulle qui avait vu ça dit à michel drom
attendait ce que je vais faire moi votre
télé je vais arriver en disant bonjour
je suis le général de gaulle et au c'est
complètement ridicule et au bout d'un
moment il ya quand même dans son
entourage on le convainc que ça peut pas
se passer comme ça et qu'il va falloir
qu'il fasse un certain nombre
d'interventions il accepte de répondre à
un journaliste et michel droit qui
évidemment un journaliste complice et
ami et s'il n'a pas accepté je le cite
d'être vendue comme une savonnette parce
que c'est ce qu'ils ne voulaient pas il
accepte tout de même de se justifier ou
d'expliquer sa politique à travers la
télévision mon général c'est la première
fois que vous acceptez de répondre sur
l'écran de la télévision aux questions
d'un journaliste de gaulle finit donc
par accepté de s'expliquer dans une
interview montée de toutes pièces avec
le journaliste michel droit mais
l'exercice ne l' enthousiasme guerre et
il ne cache même pas j'aimerais vous
poser s'il était pas ma place ce soir
michel droit qui fait des questions qui
dire à peu près une heure et demie tout
en s'excusant de poser des questions
général de gaulle qui au bout d'un
moment 1 réponse est évident qu'à cette
époque on met une espèce de personnages
dans l'ambiance de l'époque qui est
juste là pour permettre à de gaulle
dette acier donc pas verticale et de
faire comme si les échanges et s
humanise un peu au début le général de
gaulle ne veut pas faire de ce spot de
campagne officielle parce qu'il se dit
donc mais à quoi bon présente aux
français ils me connaissent et puis
savent ce que je fais depuis sept ans en
réalité donc je vais pas leur faire des
fausses promesses ou nous présenter de
façon artificielle et puis les sondages
et en étant ce qu'ils sont et indiquant
qu'il a été traité en ballotage
finalement il rentre malgré tout dans le
match en général je vous remercie et si
vous le voulez bien nous parlerons
demain de la france par rapport au monde
je vois très volontiers c'est un temps
cela n'a pas été simple
de parvenir jusqu'à vous un autre
candidat au contraire se réjouit d'avoir
enfin accès au petit écran c'est le
candidat d'extrême droite jean louis
tixier vignancour et il joue sur
l'émotion une veuve
économiquement faibles est morte de
froid à paris et voici un enfant
dévoré par un rat dans une cave où il
habitait pour bébé avec 10 de ses vrais
reiser et les parents depuis huit ans
attendait un autre logement le chef de
cave il faisait du storytelling avant
les autres il raconte une histoire en
considérant qu'au lieu d'utiliser des
concepts c'est en racontant une histoire
qu'on pouvait frapper la tête des gens
donc déjà la tête et le coeur donc
c'était relativement efficace alors
qu'en fait ils étaient démunis parce
qu'ils étaient derrière un bureau et
qu'il avait rien la campagne télévisée
de 1965 ce sont donc 8 libre de 15
minutes autorisé pour chaque candidat
soit 2h d'écran pour chacun des clips
qui vont changer à tout jamais la
manière de faire de la politique en
france c'est révolutionnaire un cesser
ces images qui nous semble très terne
est énorme parce que c'est comme ont
tous deux heures de temps d'antenne pour
des gens qui parfois ne se sont jamais
exprimé à la télévision n'ont jamais été
montrées à la télévision c'est en soi
assez révolutionnaire à paris certains
théâtres des cas l'heure du début des
représentations parce que les gens
massivement regarde la campagne
télévisée les gens commencent à être
assez nombreux à être équipés une
minorité assez importante et où on va
chez les uns chez les autres c'est
vraiment un événement médiatique
télévision va être au centre des
campagnes électorales à partir de ce
moment là jusqu'à maintenant chers
compatriotes si vous le voulez vous
pourrez avec moi mener une nouvelle
bataille du nom en 1969 les français ont
dit non à de gaulle qui est parti le
président du sénat alain poher se
présente contre le premier ministre
georges pompidou et mai 68 est passée
par là nous le savons bien
des difficultés
se prépare
dans l'université l'agitation persiste
elle ne demande qu'à exploser
ici ou là en amorce des revendications
on prépare des rondes et des grèves
peut-être du désordre
jacques du plomb je ne l'appellerai pas
monsieur le président et je vais de
tutoyer je sais que je cours le risque
de choquer ou de surprendre le candidat
communiste lui choisi de se faire
tutoyer pour tenter d'être original mais
en fait pas grand chose ne bouge et
chacun continue de jouer son rôle comme
avant très fort pour ma part j'ai
conscience face aux candidatures de
puissances d'argent que je combats
d'être le candidat du peuple alors 69
c'est une sorte de de restauration
puisqu'on est après 68 et un peu comme
sous la restauration
on essaie de revenir au monde d'avant et
en même temps le monde d'avant ne peut
pas totalement gagné retrouve les mêmes
là même les mêmes hommes et en même
temps les mêmes techniques même manière
s'adresser au peuple et en même temps
c'est pas possible de faire comme si 68
n'avait pas eu lieu et des personnages
qui ont été très importants 68 émergent
forcément et montre que les temps ont
changé et les deux personnages se sont
évidemment alain krivine et puis michel
rocard qui est une gauche différentes
une gauche qui n'est après les
personnages qui à 81 public en mai 68
par des manifestations par des
occupations d usines
les travailleurs ont réussi à imposer ce
qu'aucun bulletin de vote n'avaient pu
faire auparavant c'est à dire faire
reculer le pouvoir faire reculer l'état
faure qu'était l'état gaulliste nous
sommes amenés à nous revoir n'est-il pas
vrai et il s'agit là du problème le plus
difficile que la gauche française et a
abordé dans les prochaines années alors
on va réussir à gommer un peu 68 je
dirais jusqu'en 72 73 puis en 74 là le
monde a changé
d
bonsoir madame bonjour mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur je
vous parle pour la première fois comme
candidat à la présidence de la
république arrive donc 1974 et la
couleur à la télévision le monde a
changé mais le style des clips de
campagne lui n'a pas bougé le règlement
est toujours le même des candidats sur
un plateau télé les textes en revanche
sont beaucoup plus travailler j'ai dit
que pendant cette campagne je voulais
regarder la franche au fond des yeux
c'est pourquoi je vous regarde ce soir
et c'est pourquoi aussi vous ne regardez
jusqu'à quand ils se présentent à 114
c'est quelqu'un qui dans le circuit si
je puis dire et qui s'exprime
régulièrement la télévision pour
présenter la politique économique de la
france depuis pas mal de temps et qui a
déjà pas mal travaillé sur son image la
74 c'est le premier premières grandes
évolutions de la communication politique
à la télévision c'est ce que j'appelle
la professionnalisation il va y avoir la
couleur il va y avoir de nouveaux
visages beaucoup plus jeune et puis ces
couleurs plus ces visages vont être
soutenus par des professionnels de la
communication beaucoup viennent des
états unis et les américains ont
conseillé à giscard de jouer la
simplicité et la modernité et si je suis
élu président de la république je
continuerai mes forces et de faire que
les hommes d'état en france apparaissent
comme des êtres plus simple ça nous
avons derrière nous une tradition de
convention le protocole tout à fait
excessive et qu'il ait pas moderne la
campagne électorale fait de gagner les
élections devient assez un job c'est un
boulot on ne laisse plus rien au hasard
et véritablement on s'organise la
victoire de giscard elle est basée sur
des raisons politiques c'est sûr mais
ces raisons politiques elles n'ont pu
triompher que parce qu'il avait la
maîtrise de la communication
bonjour les candidats se racontent
beaucoup en ce moment françois
mitterrand êtes vous prêt à faire de
même face à la maîtrise de giscard le
candidat de la gauche apparaît toujours
un peu coincé alors il décide de jouer
la carte de la vie privée pour séduire
les français et toujours avec l'aide
d'un journaliste mon père était du berry
ma mère et 2 à donges et comme cela se
fait beaucoup dans la vie provinciale
j'ai vécu dans la famille de ma mère mes
parents étaient très unie et nous étions
nombreux vie frères et soeurs et deux
cousins germains dont le père avait été
tué la guerre de 14 18 il me dit vous
savez je déteste la télévision excusez
moi je suis bien barré de lac est ce que
je vais faire il me dit cet oeil noir
qui me regardent comme ça
je me dis mais si on est bien là et là
vraiment c'est un cauchemar sylla se
passer il me vient une idée rigolote tu
sais pas d'où elle me sort tu sais
monsieur c'est derrière cet oeil noir
deux jeunes femmes que voudrait séduire
et là il s'est mis à se marrer comme
quoi comme quoi penser au jeune fille
une femme la muse et nous aussi il avait
compris que derrière ça y avait des gens
un autre candidat a bien compris qu'il
ya des gens derrière l'oeil noir de la
caméra c'est l'écologiste rené dumont
et il ne laisse pas l'occasion qui lui
est donnée de s'adresser à eux et vous
savez ce qui va se passer eh bien nous
allons bientôt manquer de l'eau et c'est
pourquoi je bois devant vous un verre
d'eau précieuse puisque avant la fin du
siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer notre projet
global d'avenir merci mes amis de
rené dumont comme dans l'inconscient et
la première fois quelqu'un de façon
assez prémonitoire à parler d'écologie à
la télévision alors il a avec son pull à
col roulé rouge il est pas dans le code
vestimentaire n'est dans le code de rien
avec ses cheveux en blond blanc et
effectivement il a marqué les esprits
comme étant le premier des écolos génial
génial voilà j'aime il n'y a pas plus
belle que celle là tout compris avant
les autres il a fait de son verre d'eau
le printemps de daim
de son clip cinquante ans plus tard
soixante ans plus tard on s'en souvient
parce que ils amis de la poésie de
l'humour de l'étonnement dans son clip à
l'époque la question de l'écologie était
extrêmement abstraite elle appartenait
soi ou hippie soi ou scientifiques qui
n'avait pas encore qui n'était pas
encore à pas apparu dans l'espace public
avec les questions qu'on te connais
maintenant de tout changement climatique
a réussi à faire passer mais manière
concrète un message très abstrait est
très difficile à comprendre françaises
français
merci de m'accueillir chez vous ce soir
et de m'accorder ces quelques minutes
d'attention cette année là un autre
candidat va aussi capté l'attention avec
un visages marquants et un ton percutant
si vous pensez qu'il faut changer
politique si vous souhaitez l'ordre dans
la liberté la paix sociale la justice si
vous voulez un état fort et juste dans
une france libre et fraternelle alors
votez jean marie le pen côté salut but
il faisait tout avec son bandeau à
l'époque il faisait des réunions
publiques avec son bandeau aussi il se
présentait comme il était
ouais je m'en souvienne le mec en
quantité les premières interventions de
le pen il avait toujours son bandeau la
communication de l'extrême droite si on
si on pense à jean marie le pen elle a
été véritablement représenté par un
corps et une histoire qui était
totalement en adéquation avec le message
il parler d'autorité il parlait du rejet
de l'autre avec son corps d'homme solide
violent et de certains médias il
apparaissait et avant même de parler et
communiquer quelque chose de qui
correspondait tout à fait son à son
message une présence physique et un
visage qui incarne le message c'est
aussi le cas de la première femme
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
cette année là arlette laguiller et bien
oui je suis une femme et j'ose me
présenter comme candidat à la présidence
de cette république d'homme c'est légal
et pourtant cela choque cela paraît
étrange même aux hommes de gauche et
cela doit l'être puisque je suis la
seule à 74 à envoyer à la grisaille des
candidats et aux fesses que c'étaient
des hommes en costume cravate sombre
donc ça va envoyer une forme
d'uniformité face à laquelle la figure
de d'arlette laguiller contraste est à
de multiples autistes c'est une femme
elle était jeune elle avait détenu
jones homme de son âge et par ailleurs
elle avait un discours politique
extrêmement articulé et donc qui
contrastait avec les deux candidats
s'étaient peuple
c'était encore plus étonnant de voir une
femme un parler à phraser une tenue
vestimentaire
et là on comprend bien que le peuple ne
s'est pas la télévision mais c'est le
président il ya une question que j'ai
envie de vous poser depuis bien
longtemps
est ce qu'il est possible quand on
occupe des fonctions de garder le
contact avec les français de savoir
qu'ils sont de savoir ce qu'ils pensent
et de percevoir vraiment ce qu'ils
attendent de leur président je pense que
c'est possible de toute façon c'est un
problème qui serait le même pour tout
président en 1981 les candidats sont
encore et toujours interrogé sur un
plateau de télévision giscard président
depuis sept ans tente de rejouer le coup
de la proximité avec les français avec
l'aide de la speakerine vedettes du
moment
que la plupart du temps d'apprendre
beaucoup de choses chez les pc ou en
allant acheter un paquet de cigarettes
que tu avais du coin je voulais dire je
n'y allais pas tout de même fait pas
qu'est ce que le ch me croire mais je
peux vous dire par exemple dimanche
dernier nous rentrions à la campagne
nous avons eu une panne de une peine
d'auto une panne
de débrayage alors nous sommes allés en
eau libre heureusement jusqu'au prochain
garage ça va les faire réparer la
voiture au garage et dans la vie d'un
courant et même beaucoup d'occasions de
rencontres avec les françaises et les
français dès le matin seront tous les
promenades autour de l'elysée et
j'envoie et il est le bon jour nous
parlons des changes en quelques
réflexions si mitterrand nous sommes
ensemble pour un bon moment et je crois
qu'on n'en a pas trop de temps que j'ai
beaucoup de questions à vous poser des
tests très précis et très ponctuel je
crois à trois jours du scrutin face
imposent une jeune journaliste encore
peu connues est de son côté le candidat
socialiste qui s'est beaucoup améliorée
propre et accepte même les gros plans le
véritable problème de cette campagne
c'est de savoir si on aura une autre
politique qui nous permettra de
retrouver de l'espoir par le le
changement une capacité créatrice
d'avoir envie quoi d'être la france
telle que peut-être la france je dois
dire aux françaises et aux français qui
m'écoutent je dois leur dire
réfléchissez la france est vraiment
autre chose qu'un pays frileux un pays
heureux on va quand même pas vous faire
le coup une fois de plus aux gt pas du
tout un économiste quoi que ce soit
j'étais un homme de télévision un homme
de comme on parle à un acteur je parlais
à nos politiques essayez délit créé un
climat vous pouvez mélanger sérieux
émotions oui peut-être ou tu regardes à
bon escient n'a pas là si le type qui te
parle elle a laissé des questions aussi
bête que ça il fallait que les regards
soient chez les français et les
françaises fric soit là il faut
apprendre à près apprivoisée le
la caméra cette année noire
j'étais sale avec mitterrand est un
joueur lui même ce président
le physique d'abord
et il ne fait pas comme une socialiste
qui dit tout ça c'est de la forme la
forme c'est le fond qui remonte à la
surface donc si vous n'avez pas la forme
le fond ne passera pas donc c'est la
première chose qu'il faut faire je
souffrais pas mêler de ce qui ne me
regarde pas mais vous avez intérieur de
la rive droite de prendre un tailleur de
la rive gauche
et puis monsieur le président et j'ai
une grande respiration comme ça je suis
même sûr présidence il faut aussi
changer dentiste
silence de mort
qui apparaît un siècle et puis on a
continué et la fois d'après il est
arrivé il tapait changer de dentiste
parce qu'il avait dedans surnuméraires
ici qui le le le transformer en une bête
féroce
qu' il ne pouvait pas rêver à la
télévision et c'est pour ça qu'il était
très crispé et qu'il est très attention
ne pas montrer sa mère dont il parlait
la bouche serré et longue vie mais
qu'est ce que c'est que que ce mec est
fermé comme tout qui s'ouvre pas parce
que vous savez que la règle la
télévision c'est 70 36 70 % ça ce que
l'on retient la télévision 70% cessa 15%
c'est la gestuelle qui fait partie aussi
de ça il ne reste que 15 % pour le dit
le dit ne comptent que pour 15% et reçu
que pour 15% après dans les reprises des
journalistes ledit va reprendre sa
puissance et on finira par oublier le
reste mais la première impression celle
qu'on reçoit quand on est face à l'écran
c'est ça ce chirac dans la première
intervention télévisée de la campagne
officielle vous avez proposé aux
françaises et aux français le renouveau
dans la sécurité pour faire bonne
impression dans ses clips de campagne
officielle le candidat chirac lui va
demander à son plus fidèle lieutenant
alain juppé de lui poser des questions
et il va inaugurer son style inimitable
c'est évidemment un projet politique
précis et c'est également une exigence
pour le français vous sentez bien et je
le vois davantage chaque jour en
parcourant nos provinces le métropole ou
d'outre-mer que nos compatriotes veulent
le changement le candidat du parti
communiste georges marchais demande lui
à ses deux plus proches collaborateurs
de lui poser des questions avec un
morceau de charbon au milieu de la table
il inaugure lui aussi son ton inimitable
on parle toujours justes l'historien
local mais pour qu'il y ait justice
sociale il faut prendre ces mesures là
et en même temps ce sont des mesures qui
permettront la relance de l'économie
française
a tous je ne suis pas seul devant vous
l'ancien premier ministre michel debré
invite lui trois personnes en plateau
mais il va se faire voler la vedette par
l'une d'elles la skieuse olympique
marielle goitschel voilà un discours
sportif
il est différent des autres discours
politique c'est pourquoi je vote michel
debré moi je peux vous le dire michel
debré est le seul candidat qui peut se
présenter au départ d'une compétition
phare est disqualifié et une autre
pasionaria va elle aussi continué de
crever l'écran cette arlette laguiller
qui dégaine pour la première fois son
légendaire travailleuses travailleurs
nous allons entendre des promesses et
des mensonges de la part des grands
candidats il y en aura pour les femmes
pour les jeunes pour les vieux pour les
petits commerçants pour les agriculteurs
nous vous le faire parce qu'ils ont
besoin de nos voix pour et 13 mois
oui
en
[Musique]
1988 tout change pour la première fois
la loi autorise que 50% des clips de
campagne soit tourné hors des studios de
télé et les partis politiques peuvent
désormais compléter le budget donné par
l'état avec leurs propres deniers
apparaissent donc des différences
claires entre les parties riches et les
autres et nous découvrons jacques chirac
en gentleman farmer
le retour du verger naturellement en
plus difficile de position des bûches
mais à chaque fois qu'il vient en
corrèze c'est bien rare et ne pas faire
un tour à la maison
je sais pas si c'est parce que j'aime
bien notre petit ce n est qu un coup de
rouge ou si c'est parce qu'il est mon
franc-parler écoute il entend il agit
qu'ils ont passé leur temps tout ça a
évolué entre se rendre sympa ce rang
d'aimable donc on voit chirac en pus en
train de mettre des buts gyan le feu en
fait qui est sûrement le vrai chirac
puisque tout le monde a toujours dit dès
qu'il est la télé il est en paille et il
est sinistre il est mécanique si
seulement vous le voyez comme il est
dans l'intimité sauf que par définissent
le sent on le voit pas d'où cette
tentative de l'humaniser en 88 on a une
séquence où on le voit c'était un match
de foot on voit à table en train de
manger un bon plat bien copieux il ya le
chirac de paix règne au sud celle de la
corrèze quoi et en plus on a le
sentiment qu'ils forcent pas sa nature
en étant comme ça il a l'air d'avoir une
vraie proximité avec les gens et c'est
quelque chose sur lequel il a beaucoup
joué tous jouent le jeu et tout on joue
le jeu de l'apparence est liée à la fois
à la beauté au charme mais c'est une
chose mais aussi à la question
essentielle en communication politique
normale et couvrir progressivement qui
est que le corps le visage la manière
d'être dans la télévision va vous à vous
constituer en tant que président
potentiel est ce que oui ou non vous
allez avoir les toffes avoir les toffes
pour être président
les toffes pour être président pas sûr
que le candidat écologiste l'est cette
année là mais son message lui est clair
et imagé bonjour
l'écologie c'est la vie et la vie c'est
la diversité la diversité des espèces la
diversité des cultures la diversité des
peuples eh bien la france est une
mosaïque de communautés
elle est à l'image de cette table
est ce que demain la france ressemblera
à cette table là est ce que demain notre
pays aura perdu son âme
[Musique]
l'âme de la france ou en tout cas son
histoire c'est ce que le président en
exercice celui là même qui a permis
cette nouvelle créativité va proposer
aux français dans un clip mémorable
marquant l'histoire de la communication
politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis dit il faut que je passe
quelque chose de très étonnant
il faut
pour sublimer mitterrand non pas le
rapprocher comme toujours humble tout ça
de gaulle et le rapprocher à ce qui est
vraiment c'est-à-dire un socialiste
c'est à dire à la révolution française
et donc je vais raconter en 900 plants
la 900 photos en 900 plants en 90
secondes je vais raconter l'histoire de
france jusqu'à la plus belle image de
mitterrand avec cole quand ils se
serrent la main pour pour l'europe pour
moi c'est ce que je fais mieux encore un
peu de communication politique
[Applaudissements]
mes chers compatriotes
bonjour
pardonnez moi de venir dans ce printemps
en plein de promesses vous tenir un
langage un peu sévère le candidat
d'extrême droite lui ne change rien à sa
communication ni sur la forme ni sur le
fond alors il faut résoudre le problème
de l'immigration en inversant le courant
de l'immigration parce que si nous ne le
faisons pas nous allons être
progressivement submergé non seulement
par la marée sociale si je puis dire
mais aussi par la marée religieux par la
marée culturel
un autre candidat lui s'offre cette
année là les services d'une star comme
vous j'aime mon pays et si j'ai décidé
aujourd'hui de vous dire deux ou trois
choses sur raymond barre c'est que j'ai
observée depuis quelques semaines le
débat politique
j'y vois beaucoup de politiciens de
mauvais acteurs pour la plupart
j'entends beaucoup de promesses mais je
n'ai trouvé qu'un homme vrai qui ne fait
pas de concessions au look qui ne promet
pas la semaine des quatre jeudis ne
tendent pas d'hypnotiser ce compatriote
cet homme c'est raymond barre
et arlette laguiller est toujours là
travailleuses travailleurs
oui je m'adresse à vous en particulier
[Musique]
sept ans plus tard les clips sont de
plus en plus créatifs et une nouvelle
mode apparaît faire appel aux françaises
et aux français une prévente qu'il avait
environ 30 ans
j'ai un enfant à charge et actuellement
je suis au chômage depuis le mois de
juin j'ai trouvé une seule façon de
d'essayer de retravailler c'est un
contrat à temps choisi je représente du
vin et du champagne et je fais du
porte-à-porte je pense que dans le cadre
d'une véritable relation entre
l'université notamment
et les milieux professionnels et
régionaux une information claire disons
tout jeune voilà les métiers qui ont un
avenir et ce qui n'en longtemps nous
permettrait à moins de jeunes de
s'égarer
[Musique]
j'ai 20 ans
c'est la première fois que je vote pour
des présidentielles et j'entends les
diverses campagnes les candidats qui
évidemment affirment qu'ils sont contre
le chômage et j'aimerais que vous me
donniez une bonne raison voté pour vous
en ce qui concerne le chômage je
voudrais vous en donner plusieurs et en
même temps c'est logique les candidats
parlent du chômage parce que c'est la
préoccupation dominante des français
quand je dis plusieurs c'est que je
pense qu'il faut attaquer ces incendies
que le chômage par plusieurs côtés
d'abord les années 90 sont celles d'une
montée en puissance d'un mot d'ordre qui
suit de la proximité à l'entrée qu'il ya
beaucoup de distance entre notamment de
prises dans la république et lui tous
les sept ans en plus sain et la
population et notamment les électeurs et
donc on va essayer de faire en sorte que
les spots contribuer à créer une
proximité plus ou moins réelles avec les
téléspectateurs on voit bien l'arrivée
des citoyens dans les clips c'est la
licitation s'est fait qu'on puisse
tourner des petits pas extérieur sortir
des studios un peu plus de moyens que ça
mais c'est aussi cette idée que les
citoyens ne sont pas que des récepteurs
passifs d'un message qu'il aurait
injecté comme une seringue hypodermique
disait sociologue donc si les citoyens
sont actifs il faut leur donner
les représenter dans le message pour
qu'il se sente impliqué dans la campagne
électorale c'est une tentative pour
intéresser les gens en leur montrant des
gens comme
message brouillé je suis pas sûr moi je
trouve qu après les années de
communication monocolore
sinistre ya des tentatives plutôt
intéressante pour que les gens s'y
retrouvent
en 2002 les françaises et les français
sont toujours mis à contribution pour
servir les propos des candidats mais le
ton général des clips de campagne se
durcit nettement
al adely qu'ils aient commis même une
incivilité pour pas dire un délit il
faut que ce soient sanctionnés et que le
citoyen le voit les valeurs
républicaines c'est des droits et des
devoirs il faut définir les valeurs
républicaines pour chaque français et
les appliquer il faut d'abord et c'est
l'essentiel
restaurer l'autorité de l'état
et que chacun ait conscience que la loi
républicaine s'applique à tous la police
et la justice sont de plus en plus
impuissante et la peur s'installe dans
les villes et les villages
[Musique]
avec bruno mégret appliquant
en face de cela le premier ministre
candidat prend le contre-pied de cette
surenchère sécuritaire mais il apparaît
en décalage avec un ton professoral les
propositions qui sont les miennes je les
mettrai en oeuvre je donne ma parole aux
français je n'en change pas selon les
moments où les publics ils savent que
cette parole je la respecterai jospin
c'était lentilles communiquant par
définition et j'ai mis toute mon énergie
et j'ai pas pu le décideur j'ai pas pu
briser l'armure je n'ai pas réussi
cc c'est l'échec de ma vie je n'ai pas
réussi à le rendre communicant dans la
vie privée il était il est très drôle
jospin il est marrant il est sympa il
est président n'est pas du tout figé
comme les dès que ça devient
politique l'impression que tout se
raidit cette façon de dire si je
m'expose au petit écran je me mets à nu
je me perds verte' parce que c'est un
peu ce qu'il disait dans son discours
ise mais moi je veux comme indice pour
ce que je pense pas pour ce à quoi je
ressemble or c'est pas vrai ce que l'on
achète quand on élit un président c'est
autant le physique que le programme ait
autant le look que les mots lui aussi a
été victime du petit écran en 2002 le
candidat qui est aussi premier ministre
il n'a pas trop de temps à consacrer à
la campagne je crois qu'ils sont et
beaucoup vendu des doigts est
respectivement et donc les gens posent
des questions et puis lui répond à
distance et parfois c'est très très bref
une s'est construit non par exemple ou
peu de questions au candidat jospin y
répondent oui tout à fait deux secondes
deux secondes d'antenne et ça donne des
résultats qui sont assez près naturel
une élection présidentielle c'est le
moment d'obtenir des réponses claires et
précises aux questions que se posent
tous nos citoyens aujourd'hui une
question de monsieur foulatier de rennes
monsieur jospin allez vous revoir oui ou
non le statut pénal du président de la
république écoutons sa réponse
assurément oui merci nous avoir suivi et
à très bientôt pour un prochain
rendez-vous de questions de campagne
[Musique]
chers compatriotes je veux que l'on
cesse de confondre assistance avec
solidarité
si je suis élue présidente de la
république je vous montrais les
indemnités des chômeurs mais en
contrepartie je demanderai qu aucun
chômeur ne puisse refuser plus de deux
offres d'emploi correspondant à ses
capacités professionnelles en 2007
retour aux sources le face caméra
revient en force avec les idées de fond
travailler plus pour gagner davantage
voilà la solution pour trouver le plein
emploi
à partir de 2007 et ça s'est poursuivi
ensuite on se focalise sur la parole du
candidat c'est le candidat ou la
candidate qui s'adresse à tous les
citoyens derrière nos postes de
télévision
d'une certaine façon on retrouve
françois mitterrand ou jean lecanuet qui
s'exprimait lors le cadre à ce n'est pas
le même la qui était d'imagés pas la
même mais c'est beaucoup plus court ça
les rares cas un candidat s'exprime plus
de deux minutes d'affilée en finale une
respiration visuels ou un petit peu de
musique et puis il revient mais c'est la
principale différence de fait on se
refocalise son candidat et sur la parole
du candidat et puis c'était matiz et
c'était pour sarko c'est une fois c'est
le travail la valeur travail c'est à
dire travailler plus pour gagner plus
une fois c'est la sécurité donc il ya
une espèce de découpage du message du
politique de manière à faire des choses
plus dépouillé probablement plus
efficace et plus martelé mes chers
compatriotes il n'y a pas de fatalité je
veux stopper l'augmentation de la dette
je propose qu'on le fasse en trois ans
je veux être la présidente de la
réussite éducative et culturelle la
liberté la liberté que qui est qui et
qui est apparu en 88 dont ils ont fait
un très grand usage ils ont mesuré aussi
un moment que on peut faire plein de
choses mais que c'était pas forcément
pertinent de faire plein de choses très
différentes qu'il fallait mieux avoir un
discours
peut-être plus structuré et ou en tout
cas plus ramassé plus focalisés sur le
programme du candidat l'intention de
l'émetteur ne suffit pas à convaincre et
il ya en face de lui des téléspectateurs
citoyens de plus en plus informés qu'ils
vont plus longtemps l'école qui regarde
plus souvent la télévision et qui sont
devenus des spécialistes en
communication politique parce que les
français ont changé parce qu'ils sont
devenus plus exigeants
parce que le monde a changé parce que
france a changé alors la politique doit
changer et avec moi
[Applaudissements]
jamais la même
revenir aux fondamentaux c'est aussi ce
que va faire la candidate socialiste
tout en y mettant une émotion nouvelle
les expériences des uns vont dans un
sens au beurre à noter des modes mais de
toute façon on trouve toujours en
général les deux types de messages
parler à la raison parlez à l'émotion
parce que finalement c'est de cette
manière là que l'on va ensuite j'ai
décidé c'est à la fois un mélange de
raison et d'émotion qui vont nous faire
décider de la personne pour le qui ont
pas voté
depuis le sommet de rio nous avons connu
les dix années les plus chaudes de
l'humanité
rappelez-vous la tempête de l'hiver 99
la canicule de l'été 2003 l'ouragan
katrina
dans quinze ans que répondrez vous à vos
enfants quand ils vous demanderont tu
savais tu n'as rien fait pourquoi
on ne fera pas d'écologie sans les
écologies
[Musique]
travailleuses travailleurs et pour la
sixième et dernière fois apparaît la
recordwoman du nombre de candidatures à
l'élection présidentielle française en
fait la guinée elle a été tellement
récurrente à toutes les élections
présidentielles que c'est presque devenu
une sorte de guy mixr qu'on pourrait
peut imaginer une présidentielle sans
l'être laguiller on l'a vu vieillir
comme tout le monde au cours du temps on
a vu sa première intervention en et elle
était là chaque fois et l on peut dire
qu'elle n'est pas spécialement de ni
d'efforts dans la dramaturgie dit son
texte si sa mise en scène puisque c'est
le travailleur travailleuses alors au
début elle était étonnante après les
gens commençaient à s'en moquer et
maintenant je pense que les gens
m'aiment rares regard tendre vis-à-vis
d'elle comme si elle faisait partie de
notre passé notre jeunesse parce que son
travail est travailleuse est devenu
quelque chose de de finalement assez
frais voilà
nicolas sarkozy est vraiment le
président qui est capable et qui en
mesure de rassembler tous les français
il a en plus pu acquérir une expérience
d'homme d'état depuis cinq ans je
suppose nicolas sarkozy parce qu'il
parle juste en temps dans la réalité ça
fait pas toujours plaisir mais ça fait
toujours du bien
en 2012 le président sortant mélange
tous les styles paroles de français
expression face caméra et meetings
géants la télé est passé en 16/9 et les
clips de campagne devienne du grand
spectacle j'ai choisi d'entendre
d'écouter ce que vous nous avez dit à
nous tous les candidats au premier tour
[Applaudissements]
c'est me vouland c'est ici vive la
république
vive le roi
sarkozy ciel en communiquant une
politique qui soit il a tout à l'heure
en plus il arrive
il a vraiment la langue gestuelle
les mimiques les jeux de regards
les silences
c'est un acteur lainière à 20 ans avec
la télévision il a pratiqué toute sa vie
c'est dans sa nature il a surtout 30 ans
de médias là dedans
dans les jambes quoi chaque nation a une
âme
dam de la france fait l'égalité c'est
pour l'égalité
a fait sa révolution est aboli les
privilèges dans la nuit du 4 août 1789
c'est pour l'égalité que la troisième
république instaurée l'école obligatoire
et là le revenu le candidat françois
hollande n'est pas en reste il refait le
coup de françois mitterrand avec
l'histoire de france et utilise lui
aussi largement les images de ces
mythiques
[Applaudissements]
le change pas
20 ans d'union
c'est des démonstrations de force voilà
et de puissance c'est une fois de plus à
la fois envoyé un message
sur le fond et à côté de ça de faire
vibrer les gens comme dans les meetings
c'est à dire montré des foules avoir une
musique qui colle c'est à dire c'est pas
c'est pas un tapis de musique et sous
les propos quand on regarde bien les
clips et de la musique non-stop elle
monte c'est à dire donner une espèce de
d'émotion collective est de faire
participer des français qui regardent le
spot à les entraîner c'est à dire c'est
on parle à la tête on parle au coeur on
parle à l'affect on parle c'est une
façon de rendre la politique
palpitante et puis en plus des images de
meetings ça envoie à quelque chose de
plus vivant qu'un candidat qui parlerait
face caméra il ya en plus un public qui
à priori plutôt enthousiaste joie lieu
donc ça envoie quelque chose de
dynamique un soutien un soutien des
militants qui est beaucoup plus oui
vivant et à peut-être sait-on jamais
convaincant qu'un candidat qui sert est
directement face à eux enfin en face à
face avec vous il y a des mois et des
mois qu'on vous raconte des histoires
qu'on vous balade que l'un me que la
sarkozie vous dit que la crise est finie
et ce n'est pas vrai et que l'autre
françois hollande prétend qu'on peut
dépenser de l'argent à nouveau et ce
n'est pas vrai au fond ils s'entendent
pour ne pas vous dire la vérité et bien
ce qu'ils ne disent pas la vérité au
peuple il faut les renvoyer chez eux
certains candidats comme françois bayrou
propose des clips moins axé sur
l'émotion mais il semble que cela ne
marche pas vraiment je pense aussi que
c'est lié aux institutions de la vème
république
si vous étiez dans un régime
parlementaire si on élisait un député
donc le parlement elle et élise le chef
de l'état n'y aurait pas cette espèce de
rapport quasiment physique émotif
passionnel au chef au président de la
république dès lors qu'en france on a
besoin quasiment d'être en extase devant
le chef de l'état d'avoir envie de lui
alors que c'est pas simplement du
rationnel je pense que c'est ça qui
débouche sur des clips où effectivement
on travaille ce lien entre le chef de
l'état le président et les français ce
qui est quelque chose de récurrent
depuis cinq ans ferme puis 58 et puis
l'élection du président de la république
au suffrage universel étaient 62
[Musique]
enfin
on compte encore
[Musique]
et puis il ya l'exception qui confirme
la règle un candidat qui ne jouent pas
du tout sur le culte du chef mais joue
la comédie philippe poutou se met en
scène dans une parodie du succès de
l'année au cinéma le film muet the
artist
[Musique]
quand on n'a pas d'argent il faut avoir
des idées
c'est pour le pétrole est aussi c'est
des jeunes c'est à dire que c'était ce
sont des mouvements qui sont pris en
main par par des jeunes qui ont envie de
se démarquer de la communication de papa
c'est intéressant d'ailleurs que là que
l'univers des années poutou c'est
l'univers de la télévision c'est là
qu'est la créativité télé vielle coup
fossier une fiction ou documentaire
c'est une chose dont un clip électoral
c'est la même chose pour mon sang de
bonsoir on essaie de faire passer
quelque chose avec avec tendresse et
émotion
sinon enfin ou rigolade la présence et
ça passe et puis il faut bien le dire
ces partis savent qu'ils ne seront pas
au poids ne vont pas gagner les
élections ils peuvent prendre tous les
risques alors que
les partis qui auront une chance
d'arriver au bois ils sont tenus par
cette idée que leur communication doit
être sous contrôle et qu'elle ne peut
pas prendre le risque d'être détournés
soit parce qu'elle n'est pas comprise va
parce qu'elle est mal comprise et
qu'elle se retourne contre vous pour un
parti que j'ai si peu de voir à chaque
fois qu'ils aient eu des clips comme ça
c'est devenu un sujet parce
qu'effectivement c'était l'éruption
d'une forme de de créativité c'est
plutôt une façon détendue et drôle de
vouloir faire de la politique je suis
pas sur celle en fasse gagner des voix
on tour est ce que ça peut les rendre
sympathique
d'aussi loin que je me souvienne j'ai
toujours ressenti un attachement
viscéral passionnel à notre pays j'aime
la france j'aime du plus profond de mon
coeur du plus profond de mon âme cette
nation millénaire qui ne se soumet pas
ce peuple impétueux qui ne renonce pas
je suis une femme et comme femme je
ressens comme une violence extrême les
restrictions des libertés qui se
multiplient dans tout notre pays à
travers le développement du
fondamentalisme islamiste si les thèmes
ne change pas beaucoup on passe en 2017
en qualité haute définition et certains
clips deviennent de véritables films
avec mise en scène et moyens
cinématographiques
c'est particulièrement le cas de la
candidate d'extrême droite c'est le
projet que je mettrai en oeuvre à la
tête de l'état en votre nom
au nom du peuple c'est cinématographique
c'est la réponse que ça reprend les
codes de la communication actuelle c'est
à dire que ça peut ressembler à un clip
de certains chanteurs ou certaines
chansons c'est à dire que les gens sont
mis en scène ya de la musique on a vu
apparaître au cours du temps une
illustration sonore une illustration
musicale qui rend les choses un peu plus
vibrante ça parle à l'affect et non plus
forcément à l'intelligence sur ses
pattes en donner un programme donné des
éléments mais faire vibrer ou tenter de
faire vibrer en ayant des plans serrés
en ayant un vrai tournage en ayant un
des vrais paysages de nature à montage
très que tu es très rapide de manière à
en gros être comme quand on regarde le
clip d'une chanson qu'on aime donc je
pense que ça parle plus au coeur à
l'affect que l'intellect et la
difficulté pour pour marine le pen a été
qu'elle elle porte son corps son
histoire est totalement inverse celle de
son père hélas en tenant un discours
sur le fond le même et qui est la peur
la peur la peur des autres la peur
d'insécurité la peur est la durée mais
adapter le discours d'extrême droite
parce que c'est qu'elle était et à la
conquête du pouvoir
ma volonté ce n'est pas d'être élu pour
être élu ma volonté c'est de faire
avancer les choses avec tout le monde et
pour tout le monde
nous remettre la france sur le chemin du
progrès et l'europe sur ses rails
[Musique]
chers compatriotes de l'hexagone de
l'outre-mer et de l'étranger
j'ai travaillé comme fonctionnaire puis
dans le secteur privé avant de m'engager
en politique
je suis aujourd'hui candidat à la
présidence de la république
emmanuel macron propose lui aussi un
clip très cinématographique et ils y
ajoutent quelque chose que l'on n'avait
encore jamais vu des françaises et des
français de différentes professions
filmé de dos
on voit des gens qui marchent de dos
c'est nous tous ces efforts et ces
courageux c'est le contraire les clips
taux normaux si j'ose dire il n'est pas
filmé leur gueule comme ça donc il est
descriptif les gens qui mangent le dos
et les français ils vont vers un avenir
vous vers quelque part c'est très malin
il a trouvé le slogan du moment c'est un
publicitaire qui va souffler le slogan
qui avec magnifique en marche et je me
souviens que moi un jour il m'a demandé
de dîner on a du nez puissant fois
ensemble pour lui expliquer mais dans
toutes les campagnes politiques c'est à
la fin il m'a dit je veux changer de
slogan parce que maintenant deux sets et
un peu usés en bar chez accédera chez
mais tu es fou
mais c'est encore le plus beau de tous
l'état veut tout dire à la fois ci c'est
à la fois c'est un nombre différent à la
fois il ya un côté marche qui te donne
de la volonté la marche en avant à la
fois il ya un côté en mouvement qui
bouge les choses être complètement
dingue complètement inattendu et c'est
un peu plus simple et puis en plus il
avait la mort des nerfs la modernité
avec lui et avait surtout l'étonnement
avec lui la nouvelle star le programme
c'est le ces candidats d'une certaine
façon beaucoup reproché longtemps à un
milieu macron de pas vraiment présenté
de programme en 2016 et en 2017 pendant
sa campagne présidentielle
et en même temps ce qui a fait son
succès c'est ce qu'il était ces images
de lui qu'il renvoyait de quelqu'un de
jeune qui avait pas fait la politique
toute sa vie qui était relativement
modérée à tous points de vue donc
finalement c'est une campagne qui est
très très focalisée sur lui plutôt que
des propositions marquantes qui leur a
fait dans la campagne
nous allons reconstruire l'état nous
avons besoin d'un état stratège dans
l'état fort d'un état respecté nous
avons besoin de services publics
puissants parce que la société n'est pas
capable de vivre en service public
certains candidats continuent pourtant
de miser davantage sur les idées que sur
l'image en oubliant même parfois le
maquillage
des clips de campagne de toutes sortes
vont donc continuer à coexister et ils
ont toujours leur public
[Applaudissements]
quand on regarde les audiences quand
même on se rend compte y encore un
certain nombre de français pour regarder
les spots de campagne et donc son peut
considérer que c'est une nécessité
surtout qu'avec le temps ils ont
beaucoup évolué et c'est à dire qu'au
lieu d'être des choses absolument
sinistre qui sont en noir et blanc avec
quelqu'un qui regarde la caméra droit
droit dans les yeux on a des formes de
clips c'est à dire que ça a évolué comme
toute la communication vers une forme de
dramatisation de mise en scène avec des
choses qui peuvent être amusantes
intéressante voire parfois distrayante
cette élection ne changera pas nos vies
mais votez pour un ouvrier et un
programme anticapitaliste c'est leur
dire que leur crise on ne veut pas la
payer votez pour un ouvrier et un
programme anticapitaliste c'est leur
dire qu'on ne se laissera pas faire et
qu'après les élections ça ne va pas
s'arrêter
c'est très important de l'équipe quand
on y réfléchit puisque c'est une manière
comment dirais-je totalement égalitaire
donne la parole à tous les partis et les
français tiennent beaucoup moi j'étais
très étonné dans mes recherches quand on
interroge les gens de voir qu'ils
tiennent beaucoup à ce que philippe
poutou qui pourtant va faire rien au
moins des résultats électoraux et le
même temps de parole qu'un candidat qui
va venir président de la république et
pro connaît depuis à 10 ans ce qui est
certain c'est qu'au mans jusqu'en 2017
quand on demande aux français quelle est
leur principale source d'information en
matière politique pendant une campagne
électorale qui répondent en premier lieu
la télévision le spot de campagne avec
le gros plan ça permet quand même d'être
un peu
d'avoir une communication qui est un peu
un carnet vous êtes vraiment proche du
candidat en tout cas visuellement
le clip de campagne n'est pas encore
mort car il reste le seul moyen pour les
candidats de parler directement aux
français choix que vous ferez lors de
l'élection présidentielle à venir est
cruciale alors le 23 avril
votez pour remettre la france en marche
le clip électoral il fait partie il est
des moments institué important égale
égalitariste contrôle et de la
communication politique et il a un rôle
essentiel de ce moment de démocratie que
sont les campagnes électorales il est
une pièce
un peu au coeur de la démocratie
maintenant la novation absolue serait de
faire des trucs sinistre votez pour moi
oui je vous dis fois que pour moi et je
serai là à vos côtés
pour tout le quinquennat qui vient
allez vive la france
fifa république
[Musique]